we are indeed with blaji dakupati who
won his game after a tremendous
battle against espinosa balaji welcome
to the show welcome to st louis uh this
is your first time playing in the u.s
junior championships what does that mean
to you um it means a lot it means to
like play against some of the best
juniors in the country and it's an
opportunity i've been waiting for for a
while
and how did you uh train for this event
did you put any specific focus
going into this one i wouldn't say
anything special just like looking at my
openings getting ready with new ideas
uh nothing too special though now take
us through today's game how did you
approach it you were playing the lowest
rated player in the event did you want
to put as much pressure as possible from
move on of course i want to put pressure
but i don't want to do anything crazy i
mean everyone here is strong and anyone
can beat anyone this tournament so and
of course going crazy you can easily
lose
and that seemed to be happening at one
point in the game take us through the
critical moments of this game
yeah well so i had i prepared most of
this i remember all the way until i
forgot about bishop takes e4 move
honestly knight takes e4 remember this
is the engine suggestion i believe so
this was still your preparation yeah
and
it's you go knight e4 d4 and it goes
into an end game but it's very
interesting still and a lot of play left
right and he took with the bishop the
bishop
um so knight takes knight takes d takes
queen takes king takes and bishop takes
i believe i've seen this before i
honestly just kind of forgot about it um
well the first thing i want to do is of
course rook f1 but i wasn't so sure if
he gets bishop h4
but i do think yeah i ended up it ended
up being the correct move um and here i
don't know yet what i was supposed to do
after bishop h4 but
it seems like i should have play there
absolutely i think something like b5
followed by bishop to a3 yeah
quite uh quite good for you right now uh
but you decided to cut off the bishop
with g3 you still have tremendous
compensation for your pawn
yeah and from there i started going a
bit wrong i think i i couldn't find any
plan and
um i was just trying to get a good
bishop on d5 but it was always under c6
i was always in trouble i think and at
this point already i felt it was not too
good for me
absolutely and he did have a chance to
at some point play the move f5 so let's
keep going
perhaps here
were you surprised that he did not play
the move f5 it just seemed like
the
liberation that black wants from this
position just yeah i think so i think he
might have been worried about some
bishop e6 type of stuff
um and what's probably what i was going
to do but i think it's still i think f4
maybe even end
and i i mean it's two result game i
believe seems like black is starting to
play for a win yeah
and he uh did not take that chance
decided to allow you to set up this uh
bind on the file were you happy to see
this
yeah i was and then i realized um
there was some stuff i there's some
counterplay i missed on the g file
and it was not too good there
still you got c5 in and it seems like
the tide was turning right now yeah from
here i felt i was in a bit safer
position
um not only safer but maybe even push
forward yeah i think here actually he
can go rook hfit maybe and it's just
i don't think i can win this i think
that was instead of luke c8 the answer
roxy at rook hf8
and i don't
i didn't see it i think it would just be
some checks on and it's a draw if i'm
lucky i i don't want to get mated either
right right
so maybe bishop b6 and then check check
he decided to take the passive route
with rook to c8
when did you feel like you're starting
to gain or at least have some chances to
win this one take the full point home i
think once he started playing roxy it
already like i was trying to look for
some tricks unfortunately
i couldn't do anything but when he when
he went
for later rook up 2 king e3
94
rookie five
um when you played rookie eight already
i felt like it might get a bit tricky
because
um i mean that once i get the b pawn
there's so many tricks of the board rook
to f8 was much better yeah rook fade and
honestly i don't think there's any
practical chances of winning there
and here already it's very tricky and
yeah it seems like he went wrong there
but
and but even so i don't think it matters
too much i think the position is okay
probably still lost
you managed to find this nice b7
not go king to a6 yeah a4 that was his
last trap
well
palazzi uh good game a good victory a
good start for the tournament for your
campaign how does that feel and what do
you have ready for tomorrow it feels
nice definitely i mean not after not
such a good opening it feels good to
like grind out a win in a position i
didn't believe i had any chances
and well i'll just take one game at a
time and we'll see from there well we'll
let you go get some rest and we'll see
you tomorrow okay thank you